[Music]
after avatar 225 have recently been
shifted back quite a bit
you might get the impression that the
production will also be put on hold for
the time being
that this is definitely not the case
it's regularly proven to us by producer
john landau with brand new pictures from
the set
this time we are allowed to see concept
pictures of a new type of underwater
vehicle called the crab suit
it is equipped with four legs and two
arms and is supposed to be one of
many futuristic underwater vehicles of
the rda for the recovery of the valuable
raw material
unobtainium the whole thing is also in
line with james cameron's ideas which
always look spectacular but never like
the connection to reality
avatar 2 will mostly be set underwater
and will bring sam worthington zoe
saldana van diesel kate winslet
and many more to the screen the release
date of avatar 2 is expected on 16th of
december 2022
after several postponements what we had
feared is now beginning to happen
the disney blockbuster mulan will not be
released in cinemas in many countries
according to reports of the hollywood
reporter the usa canada australia new
zealand and some european countries are
mainly affected
currently the release date of the live
action movie is september 4th
2020 on the streaming service disney
plus but those who have a subscription
will not be satisfied with free
entertainment
according to variety the film will cost
29.99 us dollars and will be released as
premium video on demand
according to disney boss bob chappeck
this model is not supposed to be a
forerunner for further releases but only
a one-time
thing nevertheless disney will look very
closely at demand and calculate whether
the offer will be taken up more often
than expected
if this model works it is quite likely
that other major film studios will
follow
the consequences would be devastating
because the cinema as we know it would
then probably not exist for much longer
what do you think would you pay 29.99 to
watch your long-awaited films from home
or are you not participating in the
whole thing to support the cinema of
your choice
write it down in the comments that
galadriel appears on the new lord of the
rings series from amazon and is
portrayed by moffett clark has now been
known for
quite some time however as it has now
become known
this is not the only character from the
film trilogy who will have an appearance
in the series
the onering.net reports that elrund and
sauron will also be in the series
whoever has seen the lord of the rings
and hobbit movies will of course know
who or meant
elrond is the lord of rivendell and an
indirect assistant of the dwarves or the
companions
sauron on the other hand is the
antagonist of the free people of middle
earth
and owner of the ring which is to be
destroyed in the trilogy
however from bilbo frodo and gandalf and
co we will not hear much because the
series is not set in the third but in
the second age of middle earth
this also means in reverse that elrond
and sauron will probably not be the same
characters as in the movies
thus there are still growing indications
that the amazon series deals with the
time before the forging of the rings of
power
in the books sauron tries to gain favor
with elves dwarves and humans under a
false name
while elrond is the leader of the elves
under gil galad
a concrete cast for the two characters
have not yet been decided
over the course of next year you can
look forward to release of the series
exclusively on amazon
at least since the witcher and
castlevania it has been clear that
netflix has a certain talent for the
usually skeptically viewed video game
adaptions through two tweets netflix now
announced that both
beyond good and evil and splinter cell
will get their own adaption on the
streaming service
while beyond good and evil will be a
film in collaboration with ubisoft sam
fisher will return to the screen in the
form of an animated
series according to variety john wick
author derek colstad will be the
executive producer for the series
which will consist of two seasons and 16
episodes for beyond good and evil fans
can look forward to detective pikachu
director rob letterman
however the search for screenwriter is
probably still ongoing
a release date for both projects is
unfortunately not
yet fixed since the snyder [ __ ] for
justice league which had been demanded
by fans for years was finally announced
the expectations of the fans after the
failed cinema version are of course
quite high also ryan reynolds seems to
wish for a compensation for his dc
flop green lantern because a few days
ago he released a fake trailer in
snydercud style and typical reynolds
humor he calls this fake trailer for a
green lantern cut the reynolds cut
and it's a good one because even not
quite real tom cruise has an appearance
as a dc superhero he also announced on
twitter that he will not play hawkman on
black adam even though he does
everything else the rock says and that
he would love to appear in the snyder
cut
as you can see the green lantern actor
is back on the road in typical reynolds
manor
even if this funny trailer can't hide
the disappointing future of deadpool
because while the snyder cut will be
released already next year
it'll probably take at least another 5
years until the release of deadpool 3 if
you believe a statement of deadpool
creator rob lethel from a few months ago
[Music]
bye